trying to understand the twin paradox is
difficult enough without having to sort
through all the videos on YouTube that
claim to have the better or the real
answer sure these videos may say their
solutions are complete or correct but
once you've watched them you're likely
still gonna come away scratching your
head so just why are there so many
different explanations which ones are
right which ones are wrong and why is
there this lingering feeling of
skepticism when we watch them today
let's find out
this is dialect with solutions to the
twin paradox are still wrong a year ago
we uploaded this video where we
discussed why explanations to the twin
paradox are intuitively unsatisfying and
confusing commenters had strong opinions
about the topic with many coming to the
defense of their favorite youtubers if
you haven't watched the video you can
click here or find a link in the
description below it's a good place to
start understanding the subtleties of
the confusion surrounding the paradox
but we definitely haven't changed their
stance on the topic not only do most
videos not have a clue about what's
really confusing their viewers but they
also overlook that there's a formulation
of the paradox that's still a paradox so
we're gonna break down these videos in
more depth today and start taking a
deeper look at these issues so briefly
confusion over relativity is
encapsulated by the twin paradox which
asks of two twins in motion relative to
one another
if twin a sees twin B aging more slowly
while twin B sees the same thing of
between a who is really older the usual
answer is that twin B age is less than
his earthbound counterpart because his
spacecraft accelerates but as we
discussed in our first video this leaves
out a major technicality the fact that
acceleration is also relative that is
twin B has as much a right to say that
it is twin a and the earth that is
accelerating towards him and not his
spacecraft that is accelerating towards
the Earth
this means acceleration cannot be the
answer and any video which asserts that
it is and leaves it at that is simply
wrong most newcomers to the paradox will
intuitively realize
is that core 'native acceleration
doesn't make any sense as an explanation
but they lack the sophistication to
formalize why this is so now after
viewing a lot of twin paradox videos we
realized there are two tiers of
explanations to the twin paradox the
first tier gives the usual answer of
acceleration and doesn't address the
issue of its relative nature these
videos tend to try to make you think
that the confusion will resolve itself
if you just do the math or use a
spacetime diagram
even though as we'll show this is not
the case or if they're super lazy
they'll just tell you something like
acceleration is different or privileged
or that you need general relativity none
of which are true the second tier of
explanations do address the deeper
confusion and each attempts to resolve
it in their own way but as we will
ultimately see these attempts only bring
up more questions than they answer so
without more ado let's look at these
videos one by one
okay so from my perspective every second
that passes I stay in the same so
space-time diagrams can be a great tool
for understanding how space and time
transform in relativity but because of
their apparent sophistication they're
also an easy way to disguise the real
issue at the heart of the paradox
now as minutephysics explains there is
time missing from the space traveling
twins measurements as depicted by the
gray gap in minutephysics is drawing
which amounts to precisely you guessed
it the missing 3.6 seconds and this is
the resolution to the twins paradox
because what the hitch is this this time
is only missing if both twins agree that
it is the space twin who turns around or
accelerates acceleration is the
necessary condition in order for the
space twins notion of time to rotate
this means that if the space twin
asserts that the earth twin turns around
it'll be the earth twin whose notion of
time rotates and who thus experiences
the missing time this is seen most
easily by drawing a second space-time
diagram which is a mirror of the first
and which describes the world paths of
the twins if the earth twin instead of
the space twin is decided to be the
accelerating one
in this diagram the earth twin departs
at a certain velocity reaches the
turnaround point then begins
accelerating back towards the space twin
the acceleration is represented by the
sharp turning point in the earth twins
world path now in this space-time
diagram the grey missing time zone no
longer belongs to the space twin but
instead to the earth twin thus since the
earth twin now fails to account for a
stretch of passing time they will
discover that it is this space twin who
is going to be the older one when the
pair is rejoined thus if you want to use
the space-time diagram for describing
the twin paradox you have to draw two
space-time diagrams one for each twins
perspective and as soon as you realize
that both twins have the right to draw
different space-time diagrams you arrive
right back at the paradox to be able to
draw one and only one diagram requires
both twins agreeing on who the
accelerating twin is minutephysics
states this at several points which is
why his space-time diagram solution is
in reality just your basic acceleration
solution at this point you might think
well hey isn't it obvious who
accelerated if the space twin has to
fire his rockets or turn his ship around
then obviously both twins will agree
he's the accelerating one right but you
have to remember that firing rockets or
turning ships around does not constitute
acceleration acceleration is purely
coordinative it's a description of
motion given relative to an observer ki
Ward being relative the tendency for
people to confuse acceleration with
other phenomena is explained in greater
length in a prior video of ours
can you feel force which you can find a
link to in the description below all
right now back to the videos now we
wanted to put silence asylums video in
the second tier of twin paradox
explanations because at least in the
first half of the video it actually does
a pretty good job of touching on the
deeper confusions of the paradox
having one of the observers accelerate
just adds another measurement to the
list of things they disagree on forces
are now on the list it's not that
significant of a change it certainly
doesn't make one person right in another
person wrong it just makes them more
relative but then he takes ten steps
backwards by emphasizing that it's the
mathematics which somehow solve the
issue it's rule number three
we forgot rule number three we have to
use the correct coordinate
transformation like minutephysics
he also goes on to insist on the
importance of drawing a spacetime
diagram but his video only grows more
and more confusing at one point he
asserts that you don't need to have the
twins accelerate to illustrate the
paradox this paradox does not require
accelerations it persists even if rocket
clone go to the same velocity the whole
time then almost immediately afterwards
he contradicts himself by saying you do
need to have the twins accelerate
without the acceleration we only get one
shared event the acceleration gives us a
second shared event it's hard to say
exactly what is supposed to be the
takeaway from this video but certainly
it adds to the impression many viewers
mistakenly have that the paradox is
somehow the result of doing the math
wrong now in physics math is simply a
model that follows our assumptions
certainly doing the math wrong is going
to confuse you but as long as your
axioms are consistent the math won't
create paradoxes so this should be the
first clue that you shouldn't need math
to understand what breaks the symmetry
of the twin paradox the second clue is
that we already did the math back when
we dealt with the space-time diagrams
space-time diagrams are just graphical
representations of the Lorentz
transformations which are the
mathematical tools for handling special
relativity and since we already know
space-time diagrams don't resolve the
paradox then we should realize that
neither will the Lorentz transformations
however for those of our more skeptical
viewers were going to briefly show where
the math breaks down all right here we
go
so albert blasts off at half the speed
of light away from Emmy after two years
on her clock she sees him turn around
and can calculate via the Lorentz
transformations what his coordinates
should read after doing the calculations
she'll get that his clock coordinate at
a Turner
reads the square root of three years and
that his space coordinate reads zero now
Albert can use the backwards
transformations to see what her cornets
for this measurement read and he'll
confirmed they'll read two years and one
light year distance away however what if
he wants to calculate what her corn is
to read in his frame well for him she's
the one in motion so he can use the
exact same forward transformation that
she used but just with slightly
different initial conditions namely that
her velocity is negative 1/2 the speed
of light thus using the forward
transformations he'll see her blast away
at half the speed of light and after the
square root of three years he sees that
she turns around after doing the Lorentz
calculations he'll get that her space
cornet corresponding to the turnaround
point reads zero and that her time
coordinate reads one and a half years
thus to summarize when Albert reaches
the turnaround point Emmy will calculate
that only about one point seven three
years has elapsed for him and two years
for her but in Albert's frame when Emmy
reaches the turnaround point he will
calculate that while one point seven
three years has indeed elapsed for him
only one point five years has elapsed
for her thus both twins at this point
can claim the other is younger now on
the return journey both twins can
essentially repeat these calculations
and get the same durations of elapsed
time as they calculated for the outward
journey thus Emmy now claims four years
have passed for her and about three
point four for Albert while Albert
claims three point four years have
passed for him but only three years for
her but there's one part of the
calculation still missing
being that the Lorentz transformations
are actually differential equations
they'll be affected by changes in
velocity so both Emmy and Albert now
have to calculate how much time went
missing from each other's perspectives
at the turnaround point there's two
different ways to approach these
calculations you can model a gradual T
acceleration acceleration equation of
motion and integrate the Lorentz
equations or you can jump
discontinuously into a frame with
opposite velocity and calculate the
synchronisation gap either way you'll
give the same answer since Emma believes
Albert turned around she calculates that
he will calculate her aging through the
missing year during his turn around and
that when he arrives back his
calculations will put her
at four years of age consistent with her
actual age but since Albert believes
Emmie turned around he calculates that
she will calculate him aging through the
extra point for six years so that when
she returns their measurements will be
consistent thus even after accounting
for acceleration
the paradox still remains the twins are
telling two entirely different stories
so what resolves it well if both twins
agree that only Albert actually
accelerated then Albert won't have to
calculate Emme calculating him aging
more rapidly at the turnaround and both
twins will agree on the amount of the
elapsed time for all clocks involved so
wait you might be asking are you now
saying after all this spiel that
acceleration does resolve the paradox no
both twins agreeing on whose
acceleration is more real resolves the
paradox but nothing in the math tells us
why the twins are allowed to pick and
choose one acceleration over the other
therefore something else must be
responsible for breaking the symmetry of
the twin paradox all right so we've run
out of time to discuss second tier
explanations to the twin paradox so
we'll be covering those as well as
exploring the twin paradox in greater
depth in a follow-up video we understand
that this video is pretty technical and
not going to clear up everyone's
confusion so feel free to leave any
questions you might have in the comments
below but for now we just want to leave
you with three main takeaways about the
twin paradox one all motion including
acceleration is by definition
coordinative and therefore relative to
something else must determine what
privileges one twins time-dilation over
the others and finally three the twin
paradox isn't easy to understand it's
difficult and it takes work and anyone
who tells you otherwise probably doesn't
understand it themselves this has been
dialect thanks for watching